hallo daniel wie geht's hallo tina gut
danke was machst du
ich bin zu hause ich koche gerade etwas
zu mittag was kochst du ich mache bigos
das ist eine polnische spezialität und
du was machst du
ich muss arbeiten ich bin im büro du ich
möchte am freitag tanzen gehen
kommst du mit tanzen ja das tönt gut
wann und wo super also am freitagabend
um 21 uhr macht die disco die türen auf
sagen wir ich hole dich um viertel vor
neun ab und dann gehen wir zusammen in
die disco ja super
ich wohne an der schellen straße 47 im
dritten stock allen straße 47 im dritten
stock
hallo daniel wow du siehst sehr hübsch
aus
das kleid passt sehr gut danke für das
kompliment daniel vier bitte ich habe
noch blumen mitgebracht so süß vielen
dank ich werde die blumen kurz in eine
vase stellen dann können wir gehen gut
ich warte hier auf dich oh nein es gibt
schon eine warteschlange vor dem eingang
das ist doch kein problem das bedeutet
dass es heute eine gute partie gibt
stimmt aber ich stehe hat nicht gern an
siehst du den türsteher dort der ist
aber groß und muskulös ja wirklich der
ist riesig
[Musik]
wir können gleich rein es stehen nur
noch zwei personen vor uns in der reihe
die nächsten können rein bitte den
ausweis zeigen
[Musik]
komm wir gehen zuerst an die bar
was möchtest du trinken tina einen drink
ich nehme einen wodka blau
hallo
ja was möchtet ihr trinken also ich
nehme eine cola rum trinkt einen wodka
bitte
[Musik]
so here der wodka um die cola
das macht 23 franken bitte bitte 25 das
stimmt so tanke hier dein board
kapuziner danke daniel ich bezahle die
nächste runde
ich liebe diesen song
ja ich auch die musik hier ist super wie
heißt der dj
das ist dj berlinder sie legt jeden
freitag auf yahoo
[Musik]
das war wirklich toll heute daniel ja
ich fand es auch super
es ist aber schon spät 542 welchen zug
nimmst du ich nehme die s 2 a
dann können wir ja zusammen fahren
tina
kina kina ja deine haltestelle kommt
gleich ich bin eingeschlafen
entschuldigung geheim problem du bist
auch sehr hübsche wenn du schläfst du
gefällst mir sehr
der abend war schön ich mag dich sehr
danke für das kompliment daniel ich mag
dich auch du bist sehr süß ich liebe
dich tina ich habe mich in dich verliebt
daniel der zug hält ich muss ich jetzt
küssen
das war so schön
ich muss jetzt aussteigen ich hab' ich
ruf dich morgen an daniel danke für den
schönen abend gute nacht gute nach china
ich bin sehr glücklich
wann soll ich dich ab
wann soll ich dich abholen wann holst du
mich ab wann holst du mich ab wo treffen
wir uns treffen wir uns ich muss noch
ich muss noch duschen
wir müssen noch an
wir müssen noch anstehen
du siehst sehr
du siehst sehr hübsch aus
das kleid
wie gut das kleid
die dir gut es gefällt mir
es gefällt mir ich liebe
ich liebe
liebst du mich auch liebst du mich auch
nicht süß sein lächeln ist süß du hast
schöne augen
du hast schöne
[Musik]
du trägst ein schönes kleid